let's go to our next caller from the 701
area code who's there I'm Sadie from
North Dakota
go ahead Katie North Dakota I think this
might be our first call from there what
does that like um very red very deep red
yeah um in its ad it's Shady
Sadie with an S yep stay D my question
for you is being up here like I said
it's really read in the news really
focuses on that angle and it's so
different from even just watching like
MSNBC or CNN so their views obviously
are really skewed and trying to present
any other evidence is nearly impossible
and I was just curious if you thought
there was any way to get around that
well you've got to seek out your own
news sources right now not to be clear
you're talking about the local news
there right like the local news stations
are just all it's all there's like a
built in right wing yeah interview right
yep yeah well listen you've got the
Internet yeah so that's all anyone is
exposed to so trying to have a
conversation with anyone you know this
is the only news they've heard they
haven't heard any other point of view
yeah so it's really hard to have a
conversation yeah I don't envy that I
mean I think all you can do as an
individual is tell people that there are
other news sources and other
perspectives but obviously the echo
chamber effect and the filter bubble
effect is really really bad and if
you've got people there that get all
their news from the local right-wing
North Dakota news stations and then they
watch Fox News it's gonna and all their
friends on Facebook or sharing
right-wing stuff this is a major problem
I've lectured about this at colleges and
I don't have an answer unfortunately I
don't know how to break the filter
bubble it sort of depends on people like
you to say you should at least get some
other ideas in your media diet you know
and I think probably most people
depressingly will be pretty resistant to
that yeah so far they have been yeah
I've tried but it's it's hard yeah I
wish there is a solution because I know
it's not just a problem here
it's all over oh it's everywhere yeah I
mean I think it's worse there because
you know I think like in Boston the
local news is probably somewhat more
balanced to some degree although people
are sometimes shocked by how right-wing
local news is in Boston hey listen I'm
curious someone earlier who called from
a small town in Tennessee what's the
best restaurant where you live in North
Dakota um any of the small town
restaurants really where everything is
like home-cooked there's a great place
in this little town that we go through
on the way home that's absolutely
amazing oh there's some food trucks
around here I'm actually in Fargo oh
okay some of the folks have the best
food well actually you know one of the
one of the right wing there's this guy
Scott Hennen who I believe runs a radio
station in Fargo and it's just it's just
right extreme right-wing nonsense and I
see the stuff he posts on Facebook
because I've met the guy out of radio
conference and he's in Fargo and I don't
even know if he still runs the station
but he used to it's bad I don't envy you
one bit yeah it is it really is all
right come on Media sorry yeah thank you
thank you very much appreciate it bad
out there
bad out there there's no doubt about
that